it's they are setting the tone for
tonight's debate by sharply criticizing
Sanders for his comments about Cuba on
60 minutes
the independent senator though is not
backing down after praising some of the
program's carried out by Cuba's longtime
dictator Fidel Castro ed O'Keefe is with
me here in Charleston and you can feel
the energy right and nobody's in the
room I'm really glad you're here so how
do you think this will change the tone
of tonight's o it most definitely could
in many ways tonight here on stage
arguably the two contenders most likely
to face the most scrutiny are senator
Sanders and after last week's rough
debate former New York Mayor Mike
Bloomberg within the hours before they
stand up here they or people close to
them are standing by controversial
things they've said or done I have been
extremely consistent and critical of all
authoritarian regimes all over the world
including Cuba senator Bernie Sanders
defended his prays for Fidel Castro and
he formed the literacy brigade you may
remember read that they went out and
they help people learn to read and write
you know what I think teaching people to
read and write is a good thing the
Castro literacy program did teach
hundreds of thousands of people to read
and write in the 1960s but it was also
used to spread communist propaganda
Democrats like congresswoman Debbie
Marcus L Powell from Florida a
battleground state with a large given
American population
blasted the comments those comments are
extremely hurtful to so many people here
in my area and very offensive Sanders
his opponents also sharply criticized
him why are we spotlighting the literacy
programs of a brutal dictator instead of
being unambiguous in our condemnation
about the way he's treated his own
people
the senator trails former Vice President
Joe Biden in South Carolina but could
solidify his frontrunner status with a
win in Saturday's primary and CBS News
has learned Sanders is planning to
launch a new statewide ad campaign here
those are the agreements between two
parties that wanted to keep it quiet
meanwhile former New York Mayor Mike
Bloomberg is looking to bounce back from
a shaky debate before
we have a very few non-disclosure
agreements
how many let me finish how many is there
none of them accuse me of doing anything
other than maybe they didn't like the
joke I told and a woman for Mike rally
last night in Texas CBS News spoke to
Diana Taylor Bloomberg's longtime
partner about his company's use of
non-disclosure agreements and none of
them was he accused of doing anything
saying something nasty to a woman that
is not who he is life has changed I grew
up in that world it was a perot culture
we have come a very very long way and
Michael Bloomberg has been at the
forefront of that change we pressed
Taylor on what she would say to people
who were bothered by allegations against
Bloomberg and his response to the NDA's
at last week's debate a reminder of
who's here on stage tonight seven of the
remaining contenders former Vice
President Joe Biden former Mayor Mike
Bloomberg former mayor Pete Buddha judge
senator Amy Klobuchar senator Bernie
Sanders business and Tom Steyer and
senator Elizabeth Warren they all have
met specific requirements in polling or
have already won delegates in the early
States Gail give a hell we're just gonna
moderate the conversation and it will be
up to them to give each other hell but
listen I got a comment on Diana Taylor
certainly standing by her man she is
turning into a bit of a talking point
with many of the other candidates to
address to Mayor Bloomberg yes and that
we can expect that he'll probably face
questions about it again tonight all
right ed O'Keefe thank you